Kevin Hart here in
Seattle, Washington
at the legendary
Southern Kitchen.
Obviously, I'm not
here by myself.
I'm with some
talented comedians.
Bo Johnson, Ralph Porter,
Manny Martin, and Kanisha Buss.
How long you been
doing comedy, Ralph?
Been doing comedy roughly--
what 24, 25 years now?
25 years.
Raising my kids
at the same time.
That's a beautiful thing.
RALPH PORTER: Yes, sir.
How old are them kids?
Youngest will
be 21 in December.
Oldest is 30.
Jesus Christ.
I don't even want to
ask how old you are.
[interposing voices]
What product is Ralph using?
Jesus Christ.
Sweet tea and Shea butter.
OK.
What do you guys feel
about the company scene here?
Like, there was weekly
rooms every night.
You can do a run here.
And now, you performing
for your aunties.
Like, look, y'all gonna
come to the house.
I'm gonna do a little show.
And that's pretty much
how I've been practicing.
So if you could
say through the week,
I mean, how many times can
you get up through a week?
You can get up
seven days a week.
seven days a week?
I mean, the range
is gonna to vary.
It's not all gonna be--
But it's rooms?
It's basically a microphone
and an environment?
Turning lounges.
I did a show in a arcade bar.
And there was no
one-- no one there
that wanted to watch comedy.
And so you'd just
be there bombing.
And the background you'd hear--
[video game music]
All right.
Let's talk-- let's talk
"Hart of the City."
Let's talk what
this means to you.
What are you expecting
to get out of this?
I want to tour.
And I want to go around
and I want to just make
people laugh and
make people happy,
get a boyfriend in every city.
Like, I'm-- like,
y'all I love men.
There you go.
And when you're on stage,
talent is attractive.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
What about you?
You know, it's--
you only get so many
opportunities up here.
And I feel like this is kind
of like the Def Jam of today,
you know what I mean, where
it's getting a chance to shine.
And people really look
at this as putting
you up on that upper echelon.
Listen, just go up
there and be funny.
So looking forward to seeing you
guys tonight at Keys on Main.
Yes, sir.
Make it do what it do, man.
Let's go.